options he could have one Ed it himself maybe
there was some room there short side pass scores
from De brosque and the bronze have come back to
lead and Jake de Brusque again with a terrific
pass once they step inside the offensive zone this
is a nice entry and nander going after it William
nander in a 19 point streak Matthew score number
26 come on and he scored every way possible what a
sick play that is on the sideboard looked like the
second as he was coming around he might go back to
the point and his little adjustment just throw
samon or paron me Skinner he was expecting it to
go and then the quick turn around on samon right
through the legs of delene and that's a great shot
and a great save little pass behind that came
dangerously close to too many men snatched away
McDavid makes the move TS home for The Equalizer
McDavid somehow makes it work unbelievable I mean
he just put on the Jets and chance after chance
and this is usually what happens when you start
to get these types of sequences and what a de
around the pad I mean he literally just tucks that
around the right P of lion couldn't get to him
cleanly now P behind the net St chance he scores
Pon the swed is stronger than AO the fin good
Puck retrieval from Vancouver like Carolina had
on their goal a minute ago that's as quick of a
wrap as you're going to see but still waiting for
one to count gavaris Dro for nander who assisted
on the power go in St a beauty just like overtime
but this is just the end of a period and a player
just taking the game in to his own hands nice job
of toar taking a body with him I love the fact
that once Hees the the middle taken away gets
it to the outside uses his edges well and gets
it around gson Top Line also on the ice for saan
team heill back in Mar darting him with a back H
onot he scores kale Mard he again works it around
the defenseman this time a backand top shelf and
that was an absolute thing of beauty just when
you think you haven't seen a kale M high like that
you haven't left he comes in and buries it back at
stick check there by serach and now COV trying to
pull away Nikita COV up the middle one-on-one with
CC scores Nikita COV what a goal when everything
is going sideways and backwards great players come
through look at him fight through literally fight
through to get to this pu so hard to defend Cody
CC thinks what do I have to do except use a rope
on this guy Cero's concentration on the pocket is
simp outstanding droing for Nur one timer Dy
SLE from an impossible angle dle as goals in
three straight games 17 on the year the Oilers
up by a wasn't even his best chance on the shf
had that great block right into the middle it
just opened up everybody partner he had a real
good look Locker side on Gibson Leon D he just
gets lost into that corner after all that flurry
happened Tor Cruz gave it away to pass Miller's
alone shorthanded GG Miller [Applause] scores
pson is's able to come up with a puck right there
it's right on his tape will s pass Miller holds
for long enough to get hon down and then the
back head finished group just puts him right
on the tape of p and the Cs pile up the goals and
it walks by mans right to the table naan McKinnon
down the left wing this time McKinnon Thad sh
score Nathan man Kennon took it all the way to
the front of the house to deliver the goods
har had it covered but not caught it up and
he was flying well Nathan McKinnon is now scored
or assisted on the Avalanche last six goals he's
really put this team on his back right now comes
across so much speed Carter is buried back into
his neet and incredible on this unit here with
Jack and L unbelievable a lot on it free from
Lin who is barking at the referee as he heads
off for new stick Jack Hugh swooping in sharp
angle SC haircuts Jack Hughes High stepping backs
off moider below the goal line go close your side
door and if you don't the elite players like Jack
Hughes will take advantage of that daylight as
he did there H going to try to get to the bench
no he's not he's going to try to defend but MAV
behind him he's in he shakes the shoulders and
then goes to his back hand what a pass though
and he gets a step he takes it he doesn't want to
get the stick into the hands too much and Smith
can't get across with that left hand doing what he
does best he taking 26 here's a lead pass to the
game who would have thought it be the defenseman
well with this guy and watch H as Miller draws
everyone towards him and then allone pin
and in a knock with the puck on his hip and
scores torture chamber he's going to slow it
down right to the has marks this might be his
best move he certainly likes it the pump fit get
the gender to fight a little bit just enough to
get down into that butterfly and then Elevate out
the so no harm no foul there here's Matthews left
Play scor Beautiful go by awesome Matthews GRE
tries to jump D it goes right for Matthews but
the thirding of flames on the ice with Austin
Matthews and that's not a fair match when you
get the most dangerous goal scorer in the game
there are no passengers in this game for either
team here's Pon in P nice move stop get to no
rebound takes it in what a play Alias Patterson
got his own loose Puck and took it backand to
forehand from below the goal line to tuck it in
and make it four to2 oh the nicest goal you'll
see tonight Patterson with the dangles the shot
the rebound and the Finish send off ice gets it
back holds it back pocket skips it gets it and
Patterson on [Music] fire on the Matthews R out
ahe knock down L's Puck the kneel in rning it
scores what a move by William neander that's how
you keep it going highlight stop from will that
acceleration out of a pile and then the Qui he
shrugs off Anderson doesn't impact at all pulls
it around bdar and tucked it home he's cut off
by Taves in a brilliant defensive play banged
ahead and McKinnon's got a break away to win
it in overtime he scores Nathan M Kinnon wi it
in overtime and the comeback is complete well
mckinn thought he was going to have a two on0
coming in he was almost look at him he's like
Devon you going to join me what are you going
to do he keeps looking left and last second just
comes in and burries it Hughes got his breather
he's back on the ice here he goes he's the NHL's
point leader now with nine he cuts inside and he
scores a game winner and a fourpoint night
ends with an exclamation point B this kid is
something else look the Jack Hugh's just survey
the situation and look at this shot using Ryan
poock as a screen cuts to the middle and rips it
look at that cross body I I mean pinpoint accuracy
You Know Jack was looking around who's with him
what is he going to do and he says I'm going to
take care of this myself and he ends it poke free
by Kane and now McDavid what a spin the recovery
the shot is score Conor McDavid it's not real
oh I'll tell you we've watched him for so many
years the way he works in the offseason on edge
control spin everything he can do and he goes down
spinorama pops back up and somehow that puck was
loose like a wacka you thought he was gone and he
just popped right back up as it goes by here s TR
it shoot and a scolling a scolling block by Riley
picked up by nander in with tarz William nander
on Johansson defending comes neander tries and
scores William neander William neander the star of
the show all week long with a spectacular overtime
rush and Neer just looking where's my for there
he is Marcus Jo he can't P him with me stick that
leg out drive across and he reads the Poke check
the Neil hener family Michael did you see that
that's my boy a pharmaceutic p through scores
cross ice pass from zaka this is a three Zone
goal after the save by Omar get down into that
one knee one timer just rips it before Levi can
get across another great back check byal there
showing his speed through the inial Zone coming
back doson turned it over Matthews scores again
it's tough turnover for the Islanders they have
it right now defensively that's something they've
been trying to clean up you know doson is trying
to make a pass he's got somebody right on him
he fans on it that's a perfect example you're
in the dzone they have some fresh lights coming
on you've got the best goal score in the league
bearing down and you've got a B takes the buck
wide on B back across the grave then he gets it
right back to now he with a shot scor the C up
the 300th goal of his career this was key hman
just gets it back towards the KN the net excuse
me Paul gets a stick on it and then kucherov
going the opposite direction is able to put it
underneath boski for his first mistake of the
game besser dumps one ahead hoping Miller can
get there first he does he scores what a play
by Brock besser to angle that one off the corner
boards Miller there puts it home on the back end
the buzzword was strong start to the season and a
strong start to this hockey game Miller in behind
everybody right up top backand chip Force back
Bard to dyle what timer score McDavid from the
spot where drle usually buries it in level Conor
McDavid finds that quiet ice literally on the goal
line and beats barowski to the short side with a
great one time they move itet Cent broken up and
here's aonic to Pon trying to win it in overtime
Alias Pon pees dos he's stuck it through the leg
of Jerry what an amazing performance this is but
then has the wherewithal to punch it up the ice
and Crosby comes all the way back but Patterson's
able to protect the puck a brilliant play and the
kaks withstand that late time goal thear in
front it came across and jumps the Stick of
Neil Andrew regains control of it does this near
Side William neander stor top quarter oh man you
there's a guy just been so consistent all year
and confident with the puck another example of
neander with his head the whole time and just
right over the shoulder trying to fight his way
got out here's Dre drops it for ran to get it
HS looks dle shoots and scor Nathan [Applause]
Canon slides it right past Jones He Stopped
waited popped and put it in the back of the
neck off his back F but to get that much inertia
off of your back heel poting in over the glove
through a screen that's mckinon magic out a t
up top to Ryan nen Hopkins M David towards the
net sharp angle shot and in game number 600 of
his NHL career I mean that's what Conor McDavid
does here he attacks so quickly once he gets
this spot and he's so good at just elevating
in tight he floats it above cam taled here and
Jack Hughes Luke's going to peel off like he
took a bit of a stick so he changes brat puts
the shoulder down he changes Direction Jack
[Applause] H that was nasty and J for brat
makes a terrific pass it's on his stick
it's off his stick and Hughes ends it and he
beats him just under the glove over the left
pad what a win look at the release here from
Jack Hughes now he gets it back to Hughes lots
of traffic in front as quen Hughes cuts across
the high slot now goes wide on zland he shoots
he [Applause] SC Poston in and he ties his career
high with his eighth of the Season Canucks open
the scor it's ridiculous agility here for Quinn
Hugh again we see him time and again just dust
a forward at the top of the circle he wield it
up and Minnesota able to convert off the rush
Newan Hopkins speaking about Out Pass McDavid
Cuts in Waits wait TOS it home Conor McDavid
a virtuoso absolutely ridiculous goal talk
about patience by Conor McDavid great outl
pass he just talked about it watch this newon
Hopkins finds him up the ice it's a two on one
as the Minnesota Wild get a little aggressive
to watch this patience stick handle stick handle
get flurry to biking but the patience the
skill of Conor McDavid to walk this around